Meet 40-year-old Shifu Shi Yan Ming who claims he has a very special power.
Do I feel pain?
I do not feel pain.
Shifu has been a Shaolin monk since the age of five.
When I was a child, I almost died.
Luckily, the acupuncture doctor saved my life.
After that, my parents took me to Shaolin Temple.
Since from then, I never got sick.
Shaolin fighting monks practice a unique combination of martial arts and Chan Buddhism,...
...the spiritual parents of Japan's Zen Buddhism.
Shifu defected from China on a Shaolin Temple monks tour of the US in 1992.
Two months later, he had founded the USA Shaolin Temple.
To share the knowledge with other people, it's the most enjoyable thing.
You have wonderful things to share with other people.
And one thing he wants to share is not only how to tolerate pain...
You can control the pain.
Control the fear.
No problem.
...but learning to love it.
When the hammer smashed the stone, I feel fantastic!
Yeah, I  feel wonderful.
Truly.
Pain is life.
Dr. Kamran Fallahpour is the director of the Brain Resource Center of New York.
Today, he is testing Shifu's power to withstand pain with a biofeedback machine,...
...which measures responses on the skin from the nervous system to stress,...
...known as electrodermal activity.
And we're also looking at heart rate and we're also looking at EEG activity, brain activity.
Dr. Fallahpour found that Shifu's electrodermal activity was unusually high...
...just before the impact and unusually relaxed immediately afterwards.
In other words, he had mentally prepared himself for pain.
He's been able to basically shift his own perception of what pain means.